nach meinem kalender sind es noch genau
zwei wochen dann endet die ära merkel
als cdu-vorsitzende und es ist wirklich
verblüffend wie befreit die frau
plötzlich wirkt jetzt wo die rente in
sichtweite ist da wo sie weiß dass sie
die ganzen tag fressen bald nicht mehr
sehen muss wirklich finde sie ist quasi
wie entfesselt oder und und deutlich
entspannter
deutlich entspannter
neulich hat sich frau merkel in chemnitz
sogar spontanen ungetrübten bürger
fragen gestellt und da wurden wirklich
mal kluge sachen gefragt gucken sie die
heute show und wenn ja gerne oder
schminken sie eigentlich pläne gegen
oliver welke also ich gucke nicht
regelmäßig wenn ich es mal gesehen habe
ich kann über mich selbst sehr lachen
es trifft sich gut ich kann auch sehr
über die flachen ernsthaft ernsthaft man
kann viel kritisieren an ihrer politik
aber es ist schon lustig und auffällig
wie sie jetzt auf den letzten metern
aufdreht diese woche zum beispiel bei
der generaldebatte im bundestag hat
unsere kanzlerin und ich weiß es klingt
verrückt fast schon emotional geredet
hier merkel spricht über den un
migrations packt und die afg schäumt
entweder man gehört zu denen die glauben
sie können alles alleine lösen und
müssen nur an sich denken das ist
nationalismus in reinster form
das ist kein patriot
patriotismus
deutschen interesse auf andere
ja
als tattoo dem gau land sind verboten
die dackel aus der krawatte gefallen
ja es ist schlicht unfassbar was über
diesen un migrationspfad gelogen wird
es geht um menschenwürdige standards für
länder die migranten aufnehmen
85 prozent von denen leben in
entwicklungsländern unter zum teil
schlimmen bedingungen wenn man daran
nichts ändert dann kommen die zu uns
trotzdem sagt zum beispiel peter
ramsauer von der csu
der pakt öffneten flüchtlingsstrom tür
und tor
gut vielleicht hat das peter der den un
text auch nicht richtig verstanden ja
was der für eine geistige koryphäe ist
merkt man ja spätestens wenn er versucht
zu erklären wie seine frau mit sandra
bullock verwandt ist also eigentlich ist
es ganz ganz einfach weil die mütter von
meiner frau und die mutter von der
sandra schwestern sind beziehungsweise
war weil die tante also von meiner frau
und die mutter von passanten verstorben
ist aber dass die beiden sind ganz
normale cousinen
für uns genau ich muss zugeben ich habe
aufgehört zu zuhören weil die mutter
meiner frau
ja und herr ramsauer steht in der union
ja leider nicht allein mit seinen
ansichten zur migrationspfad das ist
nämlich die andere seite der post merkel
lehrer der laden rückt langsam nach
rechts jens spahn zum beispiel jens
spahn will eine weitere ausführliche
diskussion über den pakt um vielleicht
noch eine handvoll fdp-stimmen
abzusaugen und friedrich merz der stellt
der stellt diese woche das
individualrecht auf asyl sogar
grundsätzlich in frage
auch wenn er seit gestern verzweifelt
zurück rudert man merkt halt wir sind
mitten in einer cdu castingshow
[Musik]
[Applaus]
germany's next topmodel by heidi klum
germany's next topmodel meine damen und
herren es ist so spannend wer von den
dreien hat diese woche kein foto
gekriegt das ist die frage
ja die sind ja gerade zusammen auf basis
tour durch deutschland jens spahn liegt
zwar in den meisten umfragen weit zurück
aber sein selbstbewusstsein ist
ungebrochen
am dienstag hat der mann sich sogar mit
dem jungen helmut kohl verglichen
ja warum nämlich warum nicht beide
tragen eine brille und und was noch für
sparen spricht er hat ne echt schlaue
mutter meine mutter hat mich gefragt
warum machst du das eigentlich alles ja
jens das fragen sich viele menschen in
deutschland
seine mutter ist übrigens eine cousine
von sandra bullock aber das führt jetzt
zu weit
das zu konzentrieren was mir auffällt
meine damen und herren was mir auffällt
in dieser castingshow die männlichen
kandidaten gegen irgendwie die besseren
fragen gestellt
woran liegt das wohl ihrer meinung nach
das jetzt diesen aufstieg machen können
war der druck des konservativen flügels
so stark auf die kanzlerin warum wehren
sie da der geeignete kandidat
was würden sie sagen wie gelenkig sie
sind
und das sind
fracht wird auch gleich nach ihrem
lieblings auflaufen cent ich bleibe
dabei mein favorit ist friedrich merz
ich tippe am ende auch friedrich merz
warum weil er die sorgen der bürger
ernst nimmt ja scheiße auf politisch
korrekt wenn eine bestimmte gruppe in
unserem land probleme macht dann muss
man das offen ansprechen
ich komme aus einer ländlichen region
und wir haben dort jetzt auch seit
einiger zeit wieder freilebende wisente
die auch in konflikt geraten mit der
dortigen bevölkerung ja sie lachen aber
das ist ein großes problem bei ihm im
sauerland halbstarke kriminelle wisente
terrorisieren die einheimische
bevölkerung
das wird man doch wohl noch sagen dürfen
meine damen und herren aber klar
natürlich spricht herr merz lieber über
wisente als über die vielen
aufsichtsräte in denen übrigens immer
noch sitzt zur stunde blackrock hsbc
bank wo noch ich finde interessant dass
in diesen aufzählungen bei ihnen bei
anderen immer fehlt das ich seit zwölf
jahren in einem unternehmen der
papierindustrie
aufsichtsratsvorsitzender bin
die stellen papiertaschentücher und
toilettenpapier her und das ist sie nie
eine erwähnung wert doch wirklich für
mich ist ja schon lange der charming
mehr der cdu eindeutig seine klopapier
firma kein witz beherrscht 25 prozent
des deutschen marktes nennen deswegen
heißt es ja wer im scheißhaus sitzt
sollte nicht mit steinen werfen als es
alte sprichwort und es ist schon
bemerkenswert dass ganz deutschland
jetzt schon seit wochen über den
reichtum des friedrich merz diskutiert
sind wir vielleicht doch eine
neidgesellschaft drehen wir darüber mit
dem kollegen holger stockhaus vom zdf
politbarometer holger was erwarten die
deutschen eigentlich vom nächsten
kanzler
schön dass sie das fragen da haben wir
ein relativ klares meinungsbild
herreweghe 29,5 prozent der deutschen
wünschen sich ein frisches
unverbrauchtes gesicht dass ihnen total
vertraut ist 30,5 sagen prozent sagen
sie wollen in keinem fall einen mann
aber auch nicht unbedingt eine frau und
eine klare mehrheit von 31 prozent sagt
der kommende kanzler sollen nicht aus
einer großstadt kommen aber auch nicht
aus wenn man das ist ja wirklich
überhaupt nicht interessant
das ist richtig dafür bin ich bekannt
bodenständigkeit herweck ist laut
unseren umfragen besonders wichtig die
menschen wollen politiker die noch
wissen was ein pfund butter kostet
wissen sie noch was ein stück butter
kostet an die und ja klar dass so 15
euro roundabout werde müsste ich kurz
unsere zugehfrau anrufen und schon sind
sie raus herberge kein kanzler potenzial
im gegensatz zu friedrich merz der weiß
wie heucheln geht benutzen sie auch
öffentlich-rechtliche verkehrsmittel ich
bin heute morgen bereits mit der u-bahn
mit der u2 hierher gekommen
toll oder mit der u2 gut man muss dazu
sagen ihm gehört die u2 das ist eine
private waren aber trotzdem ich sage
immer wenn sich ein einfacher millionär
schon rechtfertigen muss wie kalt ist
deutschland geworden von mir kriegt
friedrich merz 5 punkte auf der gerd
schröder skala für bodenständigkeit
glichen schröder ist der maßstab na klar
wer denn sonst erwecke schröder das ist
der goldstandard mehr anbietern beim
pöbel geht gar nicht eine flasche bier
sonst streik ich hier und schreibe nicht
weiter
wir sehen
so und jetzt stellen sie sich mal nur
eine sekunde vor wie jens spahn besoffen
mit annegret kramp karrenbauer discofox
tanzen
das funktioniert nicht wenn sie
vergessen zur sonntag
zwar muss doch gar nicht sich anbiedern
und märz muss ich auch nicht
rechtfertigen für die vielen millionen
wir führten die völlig falschen debatten
es geht um lobbyismus nach unseren
umfragen geht es um selbstmarketing
sie müssen es wenigstens für ein paar
minuten am tag schaffen wie ein ganz
normaler mensch rüberzukommen nie den
kontakt zum einfachen volk verlieren
oder wie verwaltungs forscher das nennen
steinbrücken der verlässlichste kumpel
übrigens in der zeit werde ich mich
immer daran erinnern ist ein hamburger
maurergeselle gewesen die seit 1969 nie
wieder gesehen habe
wie ein verkehrsunfall mit einem will
weghören aber man kann nicht nein
herreweghe der der deutsche wähler weiß
was er will
unser kommender kanzler soll bescheiden
sein
selber kochen am besten so was wie
kartoffelsuppe mir darf keinen urlaub an
exotischen orten machen nie mehr so
ostsee und als beruf gern was akademisch
ist was aber nicht so angeberisch klingt
sagen wir mal weiß nicht physiker also
kurz gesagt wir wollen irgendwas anderes
als angela merkel aber angela merkel
ganz genau prima heimischer kost
[Applaus]
[Musik]